how did you guys even meet because i
don't think i've ever like told the
story
uh we we have but like oh no
it's okay um so let's see it was like i
don't think i was even at a thousand
subscribers but
like 800 i think 700 okay so
i was looking for other youtubers to
talk to so the last time i was on
youtube it was under another name
it's called schoolgirl101
okay amazing
this will all like wrap up to when i
meet joey all right
so i when i was like like 12 or 13 when
youtube was like first starting i had
like
schoolgirl 101 and uh i used to
upload a lot of amvs i loved making amvs
and it was like a community in itself
animemusicvideos.org
is anyone here
i think connor and i were a little too
young for that era oh yeah yeah oh my
god yeah so i i was
that website was religious to me so i
used to upload that stuff and this is
before copyright music and any of that
was a thing so
people like lincoln park i absolutely
[ __ ] did
the amount of times i've watched the one
big upload of amv
health three or that was uploaded to
youtube yeah it's just like uncountable
remember we used to call compilations
cracks yeah i remember that
dude oh my god i remember that so yeah
no i was uploading amvs
and then i dwelled into i don't know how
but somehow in my deep searching of like
anime related stuff i found visual
novel openings but i couldn't download
visual novels because they were like
really strictly just in japan
but the openings were available on
youtube which i still have those saved
on my current account today in private
but um
yeah so then i found like all these
websites and i uploaded
all of like the opening songs on that
and then they were all like hentai so i
got banned so you uploaded hentai onto
schoolgirl 101 yeah
why did you pick the name schoolgirl 101
i promise it was not
nothing perverted i thought it just
sounded cool and i was watching zoey 101
and i went to school yeah i was trying
to figure out where the 101 came out
yeah yeah because i was watching zoe 101
back then and
i i was a school girl
but like when i look back i'm like [ __ ]
i think one of my names like xbox best
connor or something
yeah because i'm the best at xbox yeah
no the christmas tree
that's like the same logic honestly i'm
glad that like i got that youtube
account got banned
i'm kind of sad all those amv's like
just like went down like this all those
lincoln paw patrols yeah i know
it was like evanescence and everything i
definitely went down that route
schoolgirl 101
yeah okay yeah that that all got uh that
went away and then i just watched
youtube from behind the scenes
then one day i just i decided i wanted
to do youtube i wasn't even at a
thousand subs
and because i was so close in that amv
community all i didn't know where anyone
was anymore so i was like let me get in
another community
joey was the first one that i found that
was closest to my age and i
thought that like he was really funny
when he was playing nico para so the
very first message
love it watch it all the time
it wasn't even like the first like the
first video of that nickel power series
but when i was watching it
i just thought you were really funny so
i was like is youtube dm still a thing
i've been gone a long time yeah so
that's how far back we're talking we're
going far back legit like so i
i messaged him on youtube and i said
subs to joe you have it this time
oh not even like 10k i think oh wow yeah
maybe
i'm from a part of youtube where
subscribers actually weren't really that
big of a thing
like it's just anything under like
around that size you know like a
thousand
a bit of a different story if i had like
three million yeah
yeah so i mean like it's whatever but
like when i so i sent him a message and
i said
i called him i called you anime man and
i was like
so [ __ ] weird but hi anime man i saw
your nekopara video
thought you were hilarious uh do you
like dojins if you want let's read one
together
no you found you found this [ __ ]
pokemon dodging off god of war yeah and
i just like we should read it on camera
together and i was like all right so i
got a call with her no no hold on but
there's something in between
but like because it was youtube dms i
was not expecting a reply because i was
like i think it was like 2014-15
times have changed but my mind was so
all the way back but
literally in an hour you replied back to
me and you told me that like later on
that
you had not really looked at your
youtube dm's until that night
and i was at the very top and had you
not seen it that yeah
this one it was like purely coincidental
yeah and then after
the [ __ ] went through the youtube
exactly
i think youtube got rid of it now right
yeah i think it still technically
exists somewhere yeah they completely i
thought it was just buried oh yeah
so you don't have an archive no no no no
no no
that's so sad i don't know maybe i don't
know if i want to to be honest
i don't want to see a message of hello
anime man
i mean that's the beginning sir right
but there is there's a video on his
channel of where i still called him
anime man it's when we were playing uh
what orange juice 100 some some shitty
yeah orange juice 100
or so i'm doing it for them like it was
what was it called oh i don't want them
to look at the video
that's what i'm trying to be so i'm
trying to be inconsistent because
there's some shitty anime yeah
yeah what i'm talking about don't put it
on the screen i swear to god
but yeah so we were just really good
friends for like a couple years and then
he got trapped in canada
and although you gotta explain why i got
trapped in canada you gotta just say
that oh yeah
because then he i lost my possible yeah
yeah yeah
yeah he lost his passport he was really
stressed but i had no idea that you were
in canada
but this is like we had been friends for
a long time and we had been calling so
frequently i was like i'm gonna just
tell him i like him
i don't even care i'm just getting a
call and that was then like you were
still at your hotel stressed out of your
mind i was like
i really like you now he's not the time
did you was there a process where you
thought about this is the right time to
tell him or you were you just like
he's [ __ ] mine right now i didn't
know that he was in canada i didn't know
that he was trapped there
i didn't know that you were like going
through other [ __ ] i was like i'ma just
tell him
or whatever i i hadn't eaten in like two
days
and i was so stressed out and the first
thing i get is like i like you from anki
dearest and i was like
there's a denny's down there like i'm
[ __ ] starving
so but then you know what's fun you were
so disoriented and also like
um so i don't know if anyone knows this
but i'm joey's first girlfriend like a
real girlfriend like proper girl
proper girlfriend he had you had seen
some other people in the past
past but but it was like high school
relationships like i didn't count both
yeah yeah so um what was funny is i
think he was so dense like i literally
said the words
i like you a lot and then he said wait
are you saying what i think you're
saying and then i said
and then i said i think i said it i am i
am dead ass of that
dense like harem protagonist
i don't know what are you saying what
are you trying to say what are you
trying to say right
i think i said it yeah so um yeah but
from there
like uh actually like i think we talked
for like 10 or 15 hours like that day
and yeah because i had nothing else to
do because i was in my [ __ ] toronto
villa that was a special moment for me i
missed being like 19 and just being able
to
spend all day on a skype call yeah right
yeah that that
we speak people do that all the time
like and it's like and it was like with
that group of friends where it's like
it didn't matter if nobody talked yeah
yeah like you were just on it